8月11本投稿中登録者90万人目指して
ますチャンネル登録よろしくです
何で夏休みに生徒の印刷しなきゃいけない
んだうん
ハハハハ
[音楽]
う今日海も悪くないね
引っかかってやんの
右右もっと
いただきます
私のスイカ返せ
[音楽]
んだよ
あの感じ遊んでない溺れてる先生誰か助け
を呼んでください
できた
だめだ届かないここは任しとけ俺が助ける
聞いたのは
溺れてんじゃないか俺に任せ
お前も漏れてんじゃないか
体が水中に沈むまで耐えられる時間がない
そんなに暑いなら冷やしてあげますよ
ありがとう海は危険な場所っていうほど
忘れちゃいけないよこの野郎
[音楽]
エアコンは電気代が多くかかるから使っ
ちゃダメよこんな
災害級の朝だったら死んじゃうよクーラー
使いすぎたら頭か
少しは
涼しく出すそんなんじゃ何も変わんないよ
子供だったらこのぐらいの暑さ耐えなさい
お母さん
[音楽]
扇風機占領しないでよ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ちょっと俺にも使わせてよ
こっちこっちこっちだ
[音楽]
これ部屋が熱いから熱風しか来ないじゃん
あー天国だ
[音楽]
あー気持ちいい
こんなに冷蔵庫開けるなエアコンつければ
いいじゃんしつこいわねダメなものはダメ
なの
トイレトイレ
[音楽]
このおばさん俺に隠れてエアコンつけて
やがる絶対
許さない
[音楽]
できた
涼しいお母さん遊びに行ってくるねお外は
有利もっと暑いから熱中症とか気をつけ
なさいよ
熱中症に起こることが多いからお母さんも
気をつけて
ねねちゃんいなくなったことだしエアコン
使っちゃうスイッチ
[音楽]
開かないじゃないの
だめだ
暑すぎる
お母さんお目覚め私
熱すぎて気絶しちゃったエアコン代より
入院費の方が高く作ってバカなお母さんで
もわかるでしょ
今度からエアコンはちゃんとつけるように
するわ分かればいいんだ
[笑い]
[音楽]
快適快適
喉乾いて喉乾いた
電気代がかかる分水道代を節約するわよ
[音楽]
何も学習してないじゃんか
これで新しい
カマキリ行け
ますお前
[音楽]
ら弱すぎる
俺の議論を倒せないよ
俺は絶対勝つからな
[音楽]
残念ながらお前とはお別れだ俺はもっと
強い昆虫が欲しいんだ
[音楽]
早くいらっしゃいいらっしゃい
激レア昆虫が当たる
昆虫くじやってるよはいいらっしゃい
いらっしゃい
俺は
ヘラクレスオオカブトあれなら聞いたに
勝てるかもしれない
[音楽]
お願いしますはい
はーい給湯のテカリでもう1回
39度は早いね
はい66とのもう1回お
[音楽]
めでとうのゴキブリで
全部引いたのに1個も当たり入ってない
じゃないか
全部まだまだ9時はたくさんあるよ
[音楽]
おい待って待ってー
よ
[音楽]
どうしたよ
今度はどうかな
[音楽]
やったか
そんなの聞かないよ
あれ
[音楽]
昆虫たちがいないぞ
すげーかっこいい
我々
昆虫の時は
昆虫ではなく
かぶすけにさっきの虫たち
昆虫の命を
扱いだ
ごめんもうお前のこと絶対捨てたりしない
から
一緒に最高の夏休み
[音楽]
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしく最初は
じゃんけんまたねチャンネル登録
[音楽]